parle également avec Bruno Darou qui est
ici avec nous en plateau bonjour Bruno
bonjour hier donc une aide militaire
renouvelée une nouvelle aide financière
aussi à l'Ukraine aujourd'hui on discute
donc de cette de cette candidature a
lieu et sur ce point on le sait la route
sera longue oui Caroline de Camaret à
l'instant disait que les Européens
voulaient montrer que l'Ukraine faisait
partie de la famille alors européenne
elle fait donc l'Ukraine où il fait
partie de la famille européenne mais
elle sait pas encore partie de l'Union
européenne et ça va prendre du temps
malgré ce que demande Kiev qui
souhaiterait une accélération du
processus d'adhésion elle voudrait
obtenir déjà le lancement officiel de ce
processus de négociation à la le statut
de candidat l'a déjà obtenu très vite et
elle voudrait que les négociations
démarre officiellement et que ça aille
très vite pour être membre de l'Union
européenne peut-être dès l'an prochain
ou dans deux ans
qui attendent pour leur part depuis
des Balkans qui attendent depuis 2008 il
y a la Turquie qui est candidat depuis
1999 mais là les négociations sont
gelées depuis 2016 donc avec certains
autres pays comme des pays nordiques ça
a été assez rapide 4 à 5 ans tout de
même pourquoi tout simplement parce que
Caroline de Camaret l'évoquait il faut à
partir du moment où ce processus
commence examiner chapitre après
chapitre il y a 33 ou 35 chapitres à
examiné qui concerne beaucoup de
domaines tout simplement pour voir si le
pays qui veut rejoindre la famille
l'Union européenne répond à tous les
critères qui font qu'on peut faire
partie du club ou pas donc il y a ça va
de l'État de droit la lutte
anticorruption la séparation des
pouvoirs notamment entre le pouvoir
judiciaire et le pouvoir exécutif et le
problème c'est que même si l'Europe est
aux côtés de l'Ukraine alors qu'elle est
agressée par la Russie en termes de
résultats sur ces critères pour
l'instant
c'est un peu mieux faire et peut
nettement de faire même s'il y a eu des
progrès de réaliser dans la lutte
anticorruption selon transparent aussi
internationale l'Ukraine je crois est au
niveau de l'Egypte ou de la Zombie c'est
à dire que clairement par exemple elle
n'est pas au niveau certains experts
estiment qu'il faudra à peu près 10 ans
pour que sur ce seul critère de la lutte
qui corruption l'Ukraine soit au niveau
des critères européens donc certains
pays à l'intérieur du club européen la
Pologne les pays baltes disent ok on
connaît tout ça mais il faut faire une
exception en fait pour l'Ukraine vu la
situation vu l'agression dont elle dont
elle est la victime et puis il y en a
d'autres plutôt les historiques la
France l'Allemagne l'Italie qui disent
attention vous citer les pays
balkaniques si on commence à faire une
exception et surtout accepter un pays
qui n'est pas aux normes finalement de
l'Union européenne ça va poser des
problèmes pour l'Union européenne mais
pour ce pays aussi parce que il y a tout
ce que je disais en termes de
institutionnel démocratique etc mais il
y a aussi le fonctionnement de
l'économie c'est à dire que quand on
rejoint l'Union européenne on rejoint
aussi le marché intérieur et si une
économie comme l'économie ukrainienne
est encore trop fragile et bien elle va
en subir le contrecoup en terme de
salaire en terme de déficit en termes de
commerce extérieur etc donc il faut il
faut il faut faire attention même s'il y
a un accord d'association qui fonctionne
depuis 2017 qui facilite les échanges ce
fameux accord d'associations d'ailleurs
qui avait provoqué la révolution de
Maiden en 2014 et la colère de Vladimir
Poutine
voilà les plus réalistes ou les plus
sceptiques comme on voudra disent bon il
faut rester justement réaliste il y a
déjà des choses qui sont en place il
faut que ça s'améliore encore au fil des
années il y a la guerre c'est une chose
et là c'est soutiens total à aide
financières de militaire les sanctions
contre Moscou etc pas de souci mais pour
l'adhésion il faut quand même respecter
ce processus parce que sinon d'autres
pays vont dire pourquoi l'Ukraine est
traité comme ça épanou et d'autre part
réellement sérieusement l'Ukraine n'est
pas encore au niveau donc il faut
finalement qu'elle entre dans l'Union
européenne dans les meilleures
conditions ce sommaire en tout cas alors
que la Russie semble préparer une
offensive d'envergure sur le terrain ah
oui oui c'est pourquoi l'Union
européenne a débloqué cette aide
militaire de 500 millions
d'euros c'est pourquoi les livraisons
d'armes lourdes les chars voilà ce se
mettent en place les missiles de grande
portée selon
de moyenne portée selon selon les
Américains un nouveau paquet de
sanctions mais qui ne va pas assez loin
selon l'Ukraine mais enfin bon ce sera
quand même le dixième paquet de
sanctions européennes contre Moscou bon
tout ça c'est pour essayer de oui bah de
faire que la Russie soit soit plus
faible et ne dispose pas des meilleures
conditions pour mener cette grande
offensive qui est attendue voilà en
février mars avril on sait pas trop
avant l'été très certainement mais
le problème c'est que en fait l'Ukraine
aussi avec ce réarmement très fort de la
part des Occidentaux se prépare aussi
alors à la défensive si on veut mais
peut-être aussi à la contre-offensive
donc en fait on est dans une situation
où les deux armées en fait veulent
essayer d'obtenir la victoire
se renforce chacune de son côté mais
selon beaucoup de d'experts militaires
le problème c'est que pour le moment ni
l'une ni l'autre ni en état de
l'emporter et ni l'une ni l'autre n'est
prête à ouvrir des négociations
politiques et évidemment territoriales
notamment sur le don-basse et encore
plus sur la Crimée pour essayer de
sortir de cet amour gloire merci
beaucoup Bruno pour votre éclairage